good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
executive director at the long now
foundation and as you know we like to
select a long short before each of these
talks and that's a short film that
exemplifies long term thinking this
month's came from a friend of mine
Daisy Ginsberg and her team that that
worked on the an entry for the iGEM
competition and some of you may remember
in drew Andes synthetic biology talk he
mentioned that there's a student
competition for synthetic biology and
this particular group won in 2009 with
their project called eco my and I think
it'll give you an idea of not only some
of the context of tonight's talk but
also where some of this may be going
synthetically in the future Thanks ikura
is an experimental collaboration between
designers and scientists working in
synthetic biology in 2009 17 with
University undergraduates spent the
summer learning the tools of synthetic
biology which is essentially a new
approach to genetic engineering using
standardized sequences of DNA in a
format that's called BioBricks they
learned to engineer bacteria they
designed their own BioBricks using genes
copied from the existing organisms and
started them into e.coli and created
bacteria that secrete colors visible to
the naked eye a quorum I went on to win
the International genetically engineered
machine competition at MIT in 2009
and joining us now is one of the winners
of the iGEM competition welcome to
science Friday miss Bolan hi thank you
so much I am part of the Cambridge seven
a nine item team and our product was
called ich Roma and what we were trying
to do is to improve bacterial biosensors
there bacteria and that can tell you the
concentration of the pollutant in water
and they can do this because inside them
they have a detector so we developed two
different parts the sensitivity tuner
and this actually tells the detector
when to turn on and when to turn off so
you have control over what levels of the
pollutant you're detecting and how does
the bacteria show that it's on or off we
use something called a color generator
which means with our bacteria changed
color when the detector got switched on
wow so they light up in a different
color they actually change color it's
visible to the naked eye so let's say if
you put a swab of the bacteria in the
polluted river back here we just change
color yep exactly
so you'd probably want to put a sample
of your water on a bacterial plate maybe
other way around well how would you
envision something like this being used
are other ways in the future as
designers we worked with the team to
explore Kramer's potential as they were
developing in the lab and together we
imagined the timeline proposing ways
that living color could evolve over the
next century the Sumari is some of which
are shown in this film explore the
different agendas that could she be
revised use and in turn our everyday
lives one of the first real applications
for this technology may arrive quite
soon a cheap disposable by a sensor for
testing groundwater contaminated by
arsenic
bacteria could also be used to produce
natural colorings and dyes by 2015 there
may be a profession of people who hunt
for new pigments and the genes
responsible bringing them back fees and
the food and textile industry by 2030 9
you can go to the supermarket and buy
the simple probiotic yogurt for cheap
personalized disease monitoring the
yogurt drink contains eco my bacteria
which established a colony in your gut
they monitor for chemical signals that
indicate the presence of a wide range of
diseases if they detect a disease they
start generating the corresponding
colored pigment producing an easily
visible output to prompt need to seek
your doctor
20:49 sees the rise of the Orange
Liberation Front terrorist organization
from the Netherlands who are angry
because a biotech company in China has
bases hit the gene for the color orange
in 2069 Google releases pollution
mapping bacteria in the atmosphere that
turn red at the presence of excess co2
as the saying goes red sky in the
morning Google health warning a
corporation meant that you chromite was
a technology that's designed from the
start and are both a genetic and the
human scale and with the long term
outlook we found that design and science
could have a meaningful exchange in the
lab which could prove useful when
developing technologies in the future hi
I'm Stuart brand from along now
foundation I remember the day of
computer hackers and seeing what these
bio hackers are up to their terrifyingly
responsible which one would want them to
be of course they're working with a very
large organism mostly bacteria we're
gonna get to the really little guys
tonight Carl Zimmer is the science
writer and that interests me because
scholars write about science in a
certain way for a certain audience and
it doesn't generalize often very well
scientists write about their science
very well and talk about it very well
but they typically you're focusing on
the problems that they're most
interested in and
necessarily how it fits in except kind
of highly directed way there is a good
science writer journalist knows all that
stuff but it's also aware of why it's
newsworthy where it fits into the
general picture of that science that
discipline and the world's needs and the
news situation so journalists spend a
lot of time keeping up not only with the
science but with the world where they
fit together Carl Zimmer has written
this beautiful little book it's as small
as a virus that he'll be signing
afterwards and the other thing happening
afterwards is there's a reception right
over there at the long now Museum and
hope to see you there
meanwhile here's mr. virus Carl Zimmer
[Applause]
Thank You Stuart and thank you all for
coming so my talk tonight is called
a viral time and it's the kind of title
that needs a little explanation it's
kind of a way of asking a question and
the question for me is is what is time
in the world of viruses I think with any
such question you have to start with
ourselves talk about our own experience
with time and then try to bootstrap our
way out from there so so what is time
for us what is a day if you're in an
airport and your plane is delayed and
delayed and delayed and delayed and then
finally cancelled and then you spend the
night in the airport and you finally get
out 24 hours later that's a very long
day but let's say that while you're
dealing with that you met some guy
seemed pretty nice struck up a
conversation with them had a drink and
then by the end of those 24 hours he's
head over heels in love with you and
proposes and talks about how he wants to
have children with you and scatter rose
petals on your grave when you die you
might say whoa wait it's only been a day
so I mean a human day can feel very long
or way too short just depending on the
scale of what's happening in it there's
there's a natural time scale for our
lives and our experiences and you know
if you look across the natural world
there are different time scales so this
is Ming the clam Ming was minding its
own business off the coast of Iceland
when some English marine biologist very
rudely dredged it up and we're kind of
curious to figure out how old it was and
you can actually age clams by counting
the rings on their shells it turned out
that was about 400 410 years old so when
me Ming was actually named after the
dynasty when it was born and this was
around the time you know Shakespeare was
writing his plays and so on but you know
by the time Shakespeare was dead Ming
was still you know just getting started
on its life it has seen you know the
rise of modern civilization
and basically might have gone on living
who knows how much longer if it hadn't
been judged up by curious scientists now
it's it's a hazardous exercise to try to
get inside the mind of a clam we can
have a debate of where the clams have
minds but I am curious what it's it was
like for me you know for that day that
can feel so long to us what's it like
for Ming was it just like a few minutes
would Ming feel like 10 years was still
not long enough to get to know another
clam to get into a long-term
relationship I don't know I don't know
but certainly the experience of time and
the scales of time for Ming very
different than say for a mayfly when the
mayfly emerges as an adult it may live
for only a day or just a few hours so I
would bet that the mayfly would be more
than willing to get married in that
24-hour period because it was going to
be dead pretty soon so in fact it might
even have proposed to you a few seconds
after meeting you now if you think about
life in terms of these timescales
when you think about a virus maybe a
virus is kind of like a mayflies mayfly
you know because of viruses way of
making more viruses happens really fast
now a mayfly has to go from being an egg
to being adult and then reproducing and
producing more eggs and that does take a
while but viruses are fast so this
diagram here just shows you the sort of
a basic cycle of one virus I picked out
the flu virus so you get a you get a
virus which is basically genes in a
protein shell it comes into a host cell
for heat for humans that they're going
to come into the cells that line your
airway they're going to basically pop
off their protein shell and the genes
are going to start being copied into new
genes and those genes are going to be
wrapped in new protein shells and then
BOOM
new viruses are going to pop out this
does not take long this can take a
matter of minutes or hours before you're
having new viruses being assembled so
that is basically why viruses live in
some ways in such a different time scale
than we do it doesn't take very long for
a virus infection to explode inside you
a single virus could over the course of
say a few days produce millions
sometimes even billions of viruses and
so when you get the flu or the cold and
you sneeze each one of those droplets is
going to be loaded with viruses because
they replicate so fast so you can kind
of think of that little circle of arrows
there
like the hands on a clock and that clock
is moving very fast and that means not
just that you're going to have a lot of
viruses but it also means that those
viruses are going to undergo changes
that are very different than what we're
familiar with because the problem the
thing about viruses is that every time
they copy themselves or that they get
copied they're very sloppy so when we
have kids we might acquire each of them
about a hundred 130 new mutations in
their DNA
but our genomes are huge about three and
a half billion nucleotides viruses are
very small genomes and they don't have
good ways of fixing their DNA are their
genes and they also do weird things like
have sex with each other
so save two different strains of the flu
come into the same cell their genes
might get mixed up and repackage and all
of a sudden you have this bizarre hybrid
virus that it wasn't there before
so all this means that viruses have an
incredibly high mutation rate this graph
here can give you a sense of it so we're
we are higher eukaryotes we have a
fairly low mutation rate as living
things go but the flu mutates 10,000
maybe a hundred thousand times faster
depending on the estimates you see so
what that means is that even inside of
your body while you're sick you're
producing all sorts of new kinds of
viruses now a lot of those viruses are
just big mistakes they come out of the
cell and they they're just misfits there
their genes don't work they can't invade
another cell they're done
in a few cases however they're actually
able to do better than the other viruses
and it just takes a little edge for a
mutation to let a virus take over the
population and this happens again and
again and again and again so when you're
sick with hepatitis or the flu or what
have you
viral time is so fast that the viruses
are actually adapting to your body they
they are evolving to fit you and your
niche and this is actually a regular
part of disease now scientists recognize
is is the evolution of the viruses
within you now that is just one aspect
though of what I'm calling viral time
now you think about the mayfly I
mentioned you know it comes out of the
ground and it as an adult it can live
for I'm sorry comes out of the water and
then it can live for say a day but it
was a larvae before that and actually if
you take the the full life of a fly it
it's not that short it's just that we're
quite captivated by being adult for just
a day so so the mayfly lives at
different scales and what happens if you
step back a little bit further and you
say well you know the mayfly exists in a
population of mayflies so maybe there
are may flies that are living around a
stream and maybe that population of
mayflies has been there for years or
decades maybe centuries at so that scale
of the mayfly time operates in a very
different way well the same goes for
viruses but just more so everything with
viruses is very extreme as I'll explain
tonight
so for example you know there are some
viruses like a cold
a virus that causes the common cold you
get it you feel lousy for a couple days
and generally your immune system knocks
it out and it's gone so that population
of viruses in your body it was kind of
living on mayfly time now if you got
chickenpox that'd be a little different
because the chickenpox might retreat
into your nervous system and then come
out decades later and cause you shingles
so the hepatitis hepatitis C for example
can and you know might infect you as a
young person and you wouldn't even know
about it
for 20 years until suddenly your doctor
says your liver just stopped working so
viruses can exist at these different
time scales just within one person but
they can also we can also step back and
think about viruses as populations so
think of viruses as being kind of clouds
of DNA clouds of genes if you think of
you know the hepatitis C not just in one
person but in all hepatitis C around the
world the 200 million people who are
carrying these viruses inside of them
you can start to ask different kinds of
questions about how time works because
it wasn't it's not like there was always
hepatitis C it wasn't always HIV these
things come into existence now the way
that they come into existence typically
is that they have come into humans from
some animal usually an animal that's
fairly like us that's because they can
use similar receptors on our cells to
get in they already have equipment that
can at least let them get a little bit
of entry into into our biology a lot of
times this doesn't work out very well
but sometimes it does so
you have cases for example where viruses
are trying quote-unquote trying to
establish themselves in our species but
they just can't manage it so let's take
rabies for example you know there are
thousands of people who get infected by
rabies every year they get bit by dogs
and bats and other rabid animals but
they don't bite each other there there's
no human rabies virus I mean at least
they're not biting each other right now
I can't guarantee about the future I
can't guarantee about what David
Cronenberg would say but in any case as
far as we know there's no human rabies
of virus so if you were somehow to get
rid of all the rabies in dogs and bats
and so on and you left humans alone
there would be no rabies because we
couldn't support it that that viral
cloud just doesn't exist in us now there
are other cases where there have been
little clouds that have formed so in
2002 for example there was a an epidemic
that came to be known as SARS and it's
short for sudden acquired respiratory
syndrome what happened here was that
there was a virus that we just didn't
know about before which suddenly hit the
scene in in China and in Hong Kong
people were starting to get horrible
fevers a few people were dying and so
public health workers realized they were
dealing with some some kind of outbreak
they were able to identify the virus
that caused it it wasn't a virus that
anyone had seen before so they said well
where did it come from
it took a little while to get to the
bottom of it so the they first found
SARS in this animal called Palm Civet
which is often sold in Chinese animal
marketplaces and so people said AHA the
virus had jumped
the civets two people that turns out
probably not to be the case because then
scientists also found a lot more SARS
and SARS like viruses in bats so it
appears that that this virus made a jump
from bats into civets and humans where
it was circulating around now it's
really fascinating to think about what
happened with SARS you know maybe maybe
the the younger among you may not be
quite clear on what SARS was for those
those of us who lived through it we
thought oh my god this is going to be
horrifying because several hundred
people died of SARS and nobody really
knew what was going to happen and people
were carrying SARS on planes to other
countries it was a terrifying moment
fortunately people were able to stop
SARS through some pretty basic public
health measures identifying people who
were sick quarantine them shutting down
some of the marketplaces and so on and
SARS disappeared that has not been seen
in humans since so this was a viral
cloud that only existed for really maybe
a few months maybe more a little bit
longer that we don't know about a short
period of time as far as we can tell
there is no SARS
now that might illustrate how smart we
are about dealing with viruses or it
might show how lucky we are or maybe
both I'm inclined to think both there
are certainly cases where we haven't
been so lucky and where we have had we
have had viruses enter our species and
get established and this can take this
can take a while you have to scale back
to you know a timescale of decades to
understand some of these
kinds of emerging viruses so for example
about a century ago there were some
viruses that infected chimpanzees now we
didn't know about these viruses in these
chimpanzees at the time they didn't have
a name the chimpanzees that were getting
them they would be spreading them to
each other through sex perhaps through
fighting and transmitting it through
blood in any case this these viruses
would attack the immune system of these
chimpanzees they were slow viruses they
weren't like a cold they weren't like
Ebola they took a long time to make
their effects felt on these animals so
initially the chimpanzees immune systems
could could ward off the disease the
virus at least keep it in check but over
the years the chimpanzees immune systems
were eroded until they started to become
sick with things that normally they
wouldn't get sick up from so over this
long scale of viral time the chimpanzees
started to weaken and die they would
they would die years before the normal
lifespan of a chimpanzee now we wouldn't
have known about this chimpanzee virus
if it hadn't been for the radical
changes that we brought to the world of
chimpanzees we started cutting down
their forests we started making more
contact with them and in Africa people
started hunting chimpanzees in large
amounts for food and this is just a
picture from the the bush meat trade
which started to become a very important
part of getting protein in certain parts
of Africa and it was probably in
Cameroon where this bush meat trade
brought people into contact with what
came to be known as HIV now initially
there were probably a lot of failed
attempts to cross that barrier
say temps I mean in sort of a non
conscious way there would be infections
where people would pick up these
chimpanzee viruses and nothing much came
of it but there was this opportunity
there was this new niche and the viruses
were replicating and there were
mutations that allowed some of the
viruses to survive in the human body and
they did better and better at surviving
the human body and going from human to
human than living in chimpanzees and
eventually they became HIV instead of
the chimpanzee virus and this is a tree
an evolutionary tree that shows the
relationship between those chimpanzee
viruses and human viruses so in this
picture the human branches are in yellow
and so you can see actually that it's
likely that HIV jumped from chimpanzees
to humans three times there may have
been more times but we're not sure and
you can actually look at the mutations
in those viruses those mutations I was
talking about that happened so much to
to actually estimate when this
changeover happened probably happened in
the early 1900s it just so happens to be
when all those changes that I told you
about we're occurring in in Africa where
HIV got its start not only that but you
can then track the spread of HIV by
looking at these mutations so you can
see where it spread to other places
there are people from Haiti who were in
Africa at the time who came back to
Haiti brought the virus with them there
were it you can track how its spread to
the United States and so by the time
that HIV actually kind of made itself
known as it were 30 years ago it had
actually been around for perhaps 50
years and it had been hiding because it
had this stealthy way of passing through
time of being hit
for for such a long period of time in
its host's that it was sort of hard to
figure out how to link the symptoms to a
particular virus now here's a case where
we can go back in time and look at the
origin of a virus we can do it by
looking into mutations you can even go
back as some scientists have - tissue
collections and they can find HIV from
as far back as 1959 but it's not as if
there were no viruses before the 20th
century when scientists could actually
see viruses for the first time viruses
have been with us for a very long time
so I want you to step back on a longer
time scale so how so how do we know that
viruses have been around for a long time
well they've kind of left over their
mark on human history even in the names
that we give to viruses so let's take
for example influenza kind of has a nice
ring to it if you just stop and not
think about what it's like to have the
flu you say influenza sounds like a
village somewhere in Tuscany or
something it's an italian word which
means influence the influence they were
talking about was the influence of the
stars that were believed in the Middle
Ages and the Renaissance to control our
health and in some cases to cause
terrible epidemics associate with fevers
and aches and often death so so you can
go back through history and see the mark
that certain viruses have left on that
history you can even see the mark on
people themselves so this is actually
probably the oldest sign of viruses in
human civilization
this is Ramses the fifth pharaoh of
egypt about three thousand years ago and
you might be able to see there are lots
and lots of pock marks on his face and
that was smallpox so
Ramsey's you know even the Pharaoh could
be felled by smallpox three thousand
years ago so so viruses span all of
human civilization
okay we've gone from minutes to hours to
days to decades centuries millennia but
it's not as if before the rise of human
civilization we lived in some sort of
you know pre viral Eden we know that our
early ancestors got sick with viruses
too now going back into that that
prehistory of viruses before you know
the records that we humans kept it's not
easy you can't dig up a fossil of a
virus like you can a trilobite but you
can look at viruses themselves and their
genes as kind of a fossil record so for
example there are some viruses like CMV
cytomegalovirus where there are some
really striking patterns about its
evolution so we humans get one kind of
cytomegalovirus and the closest relative
to that virus are in other primates and
if you go out along the branches of the
CMV evolutionary tree you go out on the
branches of the primate tree as well so
what that suggests is that these viruses
have kind of diverged along with their
hosts they haven't switched around a lot
like I showed you with HIV they've been
very loyal to their hosts and when their
host gives rise to new species they form
new species too but what's really
amazing to me is that there is actually
a fossil record in our own genome and I
want to explain to you how we know that
I want to jump back again to HIV
remember how I showed you before how the
way the flu replicates HIV and viruses
like it have a somewhat different way of
going about their business they infect
cells but when they infect cells their
genes don't just sort of spill out their
genes actually get inserted quite
precisely into the host cell's genome so
in effect they have become part of the
host cell's genome now typically what
happens is that they they get into that
genome and their genes basically
instruct the cell to make lots of new
HIV and the HIV pops out of the cell and
eventually the cell just wipes out
ruptures dies end of story
sometimes with these kinds of viruses
something happens a little bit
differently so imagine what happens if
one of these viruses the this group of
viruses is called retroviruses imagine
if it gets into an egg now imagine what
happens when that egg is fertilized and
it becomes two cells now those two cells
both have the virus's DNA in them and
then four cells they all have the viral
DNA in the genome - that when that egg
develops into an adult every single cell
in that organisms body carries that
viral DNA in it so in the sense the
virus has has fused to its host so you
know if you think of viruses as being
kind of let's abandon the cloud metaphor
and think of rivers so it's like a river
of genes going through time well now
it's river and its host river have have
merged together now when this happens
the this retrovirus is called an
endogenous retrovirus meaning it's
within now initially it may be possible
for that DNA of
virus to produce new viruses that can go
infect other cells or other hosts but
they mutate along with the rest of our
DNA and after a while those viruses just
get so disabled by commute ations that
they're stuck there
they're just we just carry them along in
our genome and we actually have a lot of
these and you can go and look through
the human genome and you'll be going
along and you say like okay well that's
a gene for collagen and okay that's the
gene for keratin and then you're going
along you say whoa wait a minute
that's a gene for a protein gel for a
virus like HIV in our own genome and you
can see it it might be a little bit
degraded but the signature is clear
enough that you can see and they're
actually multiple copies sometimes of
these viruses because once they lose
ability to the break out and infect
other hosts they could still make copies
of themselves that get put back in so
there's one of these which is called
HERV k where we have a number of copies
in our genome and it's believed that
they come from a virus and infected our
ancestors maybe say about 2 million
years ago so that's a hypothesis but you
know these this is just stretches of DNA
how do we know that they were really a
virus well some French researchers came
up with a really clever way of testing
this so so this is the hypothesis
showing how virus would go into a germ
cell egg or sperm and then eventually
would become just part of the human
genome to understand how the scientists
figured this out that these particular
stretches of DNA really were from
viruses let me give you kind of a
thought experiment let's say that today
several of your friends texted you and
said hey you can hear that talk viral
time
but you know iPhones fat thumbs you know
autocorrect what-have-you
you get mistakes so you get the you get
all these different versions of the talk
tonight and you're usually thinking like
what what what did they have in mind
what was the original message well you
know leaving aside your ability to let's
say you didn't you couldn't actually
like look at that and sort of recognize
the words let's just say you use pure
powers of deduction well well you one
thing you could do is you could just
identify the letters that were a little
different in each one as you can see
here each one only has one that's
different and from that you can you can
pretty safely assume that the original
title was viral time that these are sort
of did the offspring the mutant
offspring that your friends sent you
well this is what these French
scientists did basically they work their
way back from these different versions
of this virus in our genome and they
said okay we think that this was the
original sequence of the virus that we
think was a virus that infected our
ancestors so they they synthesized this
genetic sequence they made a piece of
DNA and they stuck it in a human cell
and lo and behold it made viruses so
here we have a virus we've been caring
for 2 million years it's been hanging
along quietly mining its own business
and these scientists had the gall to
bring it back to life so these are
actually pictures of the virus budding
out the new virus is budding out of the
cell when they put that that gene
sequence in now this is just 2 million
years actually you can you can track the
evolution of these things these things
way back one of the ways you can do that
is look at our relatives so for example
there are some viruses that are found
only
in our US and our closest relatives like
the great apes so they must have they
must have infected our ancestors at that
point in time the common ancestor of
great apes which lives say about ten
million years ago you can find other of
these viruses that in the genomes of
humans Apes old-world monkeys so that
pushes you back for their in time still
you can find others that infect all
placental mammals that puts you put you
back way back in time and what's really
amazing is that there are a lot of these
viruses in your genome scientists have
identified about a hundred thousand
elements in your genome that came from
viruses now to put that in perspective
we all have 20,000 protein coding genes
that takes up about 1.2 percent of our
genome viruses these things take up
about 8 or 9 percent so you could say
you're about six times more virus than
you are human if you're so inclined so
so we're dealing with with a time scale
that that that we carry in our own
bodies that is really you start to get
into unimaginably old periods of time I
mean I've just marked an era where the
Grand Canyon formed and you have viruses
that are older than that
in your own genome this is a this is a
deeply weird concept I mean that to
think of our human genome having been
gradually eroded like the Grand Canyon
for millions of years by viruses now our
genomes didn't you know go willingly we
actually have lots of genes that seem to
be specifically adapted for fighting off
these viruses as they try to enter the
genome and then as they try to replicate
we try to put a stop to this because it
can be very disruptive I mean
if a virus plops in and does and happens
to plug itself where there's a really
essential gene there can be trouble
these a lot of retroviruses are
associated with cancer so evolution has
favored defenses against these things
but that's not to say that these viruses
haven't ended up being useful actually
mutations can essentially borrow some of
the genes from viruses and use them to
benefit us and my favorite example and
really the most startling one is one
that's involved with pregnancy so in
order to in in order for a embryo a
mammal embryo to develop I should say
placental mammal embryo it has to form a
placenta which attaches to the uterus
and in many groups of mammals what
happens then is that there is a layer
that forms here these sort of kind of
purplish cells here
that's a layer that allows the embryo to
draw in nutrients from the mother and
and to attach to the to the uterine wall
and it's very distinctive because it's
formed by cells but then the walls
between the cells break down and so it's
just sort of a big open kind of layer of
cytoplasm cell juice basically there's a
protein that makes that happen if you
knock the gene out from mice they cannot
reproduce it is it is fatal to an embryo
not to be able to form that layer with
that protein that protein comes from a
virus actually this this has happened
repeatedly in evolution different mammal
lineages have actually borrowed the
similar viral genes to make that layer
so if it wasn't for viruses none of us
would have even been born
now I've taken you back now about a
hundred million years but really to
appreciate the full scope of a viral
time I need to actually take you back a
bit further and to do that we have to
sort of leave the leave the mammals
behind leave the animals behind and look
at really the most important hosts on
the planet and those are the microbes
they outweigh us they're much more
important in terms of the
biogeochemistry or the planet this is
really a microbial planet and those
microbes are heavily infected with their
own viruses there they're called
bacteriophages so this actually shows
you an e coli which is as being which is
actually popping out lots of new pages
that are going to go off and infect
other ones so where can you find these
phages well inside of all of you because
you have trillions of bacteria inside of
you that you depend on for your health
and survival and they are getting
infected regularly by phages so each of
you who pretty much all sound healthy
so the healthy among you have four
trillion pages inside of you right now
in your nose in your mouth and your
lungs and your gut and you're eating
them every day in yogurt pickles or all
sorts of different foods you're picking
up new phages and they're breeding
inside of you and you're releasing them
into the environment and we'll leave it
at that
we've already to have the chrome eyes we
don't need to think about these things
anymore but in any case you have an
incredible diversity of phages inside of
you a estimated about 1,500 different
species dwelling inside of you but
they're not infecting you they're not
making you sick they're they're after
your bacteria so humans and other
animals are wonderful places to find
phages but there are lots and lots and
lots of other places to find them so
here's a place called the cave of
crystals it's about a mile underground
those are actually crystals that have
formed there you know 60 ton type
crystals like the biggest the biggest
crystals ever found
it's a marvelous place they're wearing
these space suits partly because it's
incredibly hot and but also because they
don't want to infect it with their
bacteria they're actually bacteria that
live in the water that comes in to this
cave from the surrounding rock and they
get infected with viruses in fact if you
scoop up a spoonful of that water it'll
have 200 million viruses in it this may
not look like a good place to look for
viruses but in fact it's a great place
to because a couple miles underground
under the ice I should say and then dart
god there's something called lake vostok
lake vostok is home to an ecosystem
dominated by bacteria and those bacteria
have lots of viruses in them they even
actually have viruses that infect other
viruses which is interesting but in any
case
just about anywhere you look on earth
where there's life there are viruses the
ocean actually was thought to be pretty
much virus free for a long time people
just thought well how can viruses live
in seawater let's just do harsh we know
better now actually and if you take that
spoon and scoop up a spoon of seawater
you'll find a billion viruses just in
that spoonful so there are viruses in
the soil there are viruses in all sorts
of other places and so that leads
scientists to say well how many viruses
are there and obviously they can't count
them all up but they can do surveys and
they can estimate from sampling and
ocean and soil and sediment and so on
and this is the number they come up with
is a big number that's one with 31 zeros
after that so it's kind of hard to think
about how many viruses that is and my
favorite way that scientists have tried
to wrap their heads around this is to
say hmm what would happen if we took
every virus on earth and stacked them
one on top of the other they never
explained how they do this but in any
case they say well would it extend a
mile into the air would it go to the
moon would it go out of the solar system
well the answers to all that is no
because actually it would go a hundred
thousand light-years I have an arrow
pointing here to a galaxy that's
actually it would go past galaxies I'm
sorry 100 million it was you start to
you start to get fuzzy on these numbers
after a while because they're just so
many yes I'm sorry
that is correct 100 million light-years
yes so you go out way past your local
guy give your local galaxies so what
does it mean that the most abundant
organism on earth by far
our viruses this is why I call the book
a planet of viruses if you want to add
up organisms and I consider viruses
organisms viruses are way at the top of
the list
what does that mean well one of the
things that means is that viruses are
planetary forces so here's another
example of viral time viruses are
continually infecting microbes in the
ocean there's a there's a vast number of
infections that are happening every
second and in many of the Kayo's cases
they are making lots of copies inside
those bacteria and then blowing up the
bacteria to get out and they're dumping
all the carbon inside of the bacteria
into the ocean
viruses kill half of all the bacteria in
the ocean every day now what happens is
that carbon scientists don't really know
because they've just you know figured
this math out in the last few years and
they're saying wait a minute this is
incredible this is a colossal amount of
carbon now some of it is probably
sinking down to the ocean floor some of
it might actually be fertilizing the
growth of microbes in the in the upper
ocean it's probably having a huge effect
on a lot of different things one of the
things maybe is climate because by
screwing up the carbon cycle as it were
they're affecting how much carbon that
the the ocean can absorb from the
atmosphere and thereby helping to set
the climate because in the atmosphere
the carbon dioxide is trapping Heat
scientists can't say you know it wasn't
for viruses the earth would be so many
degrees warm or colder because there are
many complex effects of these viruses we
just don't know yet but we know it's got
to be big
now the other weird thing about viruses
in the ocean and this is something I'll
get to in more detail in a second is
that not all the viruses are killing
their hosts a lot of viruses I'm
actually regularly insert their their
genes into a microbial host and that's
it they just hang out now they can still
every now and then make new viruses and
pop out if they need to but pretty much
they're along for the ride
and when these viruses go from hosts of
folks they can sometimes pick up host
genes and carry them along with them and
then after a while they can create kind
of a whole kind of shopping cart full of
genes which sure they can bring to a new
host and they're actually some viruses
floating around the ocean that carry a
whole bunch of genes for photosynthesis
now they can photosynthesize on their
own what they do is they go and they
find a bacterium they infect it they
insert their genes into the into the
microbe and all of a sudden the microbe
turns green in the sense that it can now
photosynthesize it couldn't before when
it gets infected you can start
harnessing harvesting sunlight and it's
believed that about 10% of the
photosynthesis in the ocean is produced
this way penny Chisholm from MIT has
been studying these bacteria and the
viruses that infect them and she has
just found that this is happening around
the world so in every breath you take
you are breathing in some some oxygen
from viruses so the reason that I'm
talking so much about microbes and their
viruses is that for a long time that's
what this planet was like it was a
microbial planet this is a picture of
stromatolites which are microbial mats
these are from Australia and these were
the you know the big players on the
planet for perhaps the first couple
billion years these stromatolites are
loaded with viruses and so that's a
pretty good clue that there were viruses
on the very early Earth
another way of figuring out how old
viruses are on a sort of Earth history
scale is to look at the Tree of Life and
we can look at those endogenous
retroviruses that showed you before they
only go back about hundred million years
before the signal gets kind of fuzzy
so then scientists have to look at the
viruses themselves this is a tricky
thing because the viruses are mutating
so fast that it can be hard to really
see their deep history in their genes
because the DNA mutates so much that
sometimes it kind of erases its own
record of itself mutates and mutates
again and you tates again and you can't
you can't do that reconstruction I was
showing you but we've got a growing
catalog of virus genes they're being
gathered by people like craig Venter
so after craig Venter led the the
private effort to sequence the human
genome he took off on his yacht was a
bunch of other scientists and they
started scooping up seawater and
basically sequencing every gene that
could find in them and there are
millions of genes many of which were
from viruses and so as scientists have
more of this kind of data to look at
they start to see some really big
patterns to those viral genes this is
kind of a classic now classic view of
life so we are part of that Eukarya
branch we're about here and their
scientists recognize three main branches
the bacteria the Eukarya and the archaea
well by looking at these viral genes
scientists have discovered that they're
pretty weird
and this is a particularly groovy
illustration actually published in a
scientific paper but you know I salute
their aesthetics so you've got bacteria
bacteria archaea and eukaryotes over
here the three domains
then over here you have a viral branch
these are these are virus genes virus
genes that are really way off on their
own and scientists are now arguing that
there should we should recognize a
fourth domain in life which is
represented by viruses not all viruses
but a particularly interesting bunch of
them called giant viruses which were
discovered just a few years ago they've
probably been sitting in front of us and
we just haven't realized that viruses
because they were too big they
scientists literally just thought they
were bacteria but it turned out they're
viruses they just happen to be viruses
with way too many genes in them and
they're just way too big to be
recognized as viruses in any case so now
we sort see that viruses having this
incredible ancestry in their genes and I
just wanted to point out these things
here this looks a little bit different
than Darwin's branching pattern that's
because the viruses are viruses would
shuffle genes back and forth between the
different domains so so you know all of
life is a product of this this mosaic
created in large part by viruses and
this is a process that's still going on
the the coli outbreak that started up in
Europe and may
turns out it's a strain of e.coli that
seemed totally harmless before but
basically viruses delivered a bunch of
genes to it that turned it into this
vicious killer so this is you know we've
got two time scales here we've got the
time scale of last week and the time
scale of four billion years you know a
lot of people ask me well okay when did
viruses start and you know I don't think
anybody really knows that but there's a
certain logic that leads you to believe
that viruses were there as soon as there
was anything that we consider alive
because basically it's just a great way
of making a living you just you just
exploit others
and you know unfortunately cheating is a
very successful strategy in life and so
you can imagine you don't even need cell
walls imagine that you've got jeans
floating around and they're interacting
with each other and these these jeans
are being very polite with each other
and working together and cooperating and
they're producing more copies of
themselves that could be a great target
for a virus that gets those those genes
to make copies of itself instead of
themselves
the last issue that I want to talk about
in terms of the deep past of life is DNA
so DNA is this marvelous molecule
double-stranded way of storing
information and it's it's a very
peculiar virus it's a very peculiar
molecule scientists have had I had a
hard time trying to figure out how DNA
itself evolved from you know the
building blocks of life fortunately
there there's a pretty clear possibility
for what came before DNA when DNA is
used to make proteins a single-stranded
version is produced called RNA and turns
out that RNA does lots of other things
in ourselves too and so it can it might
be able to act kind of like a gene and a
protein so maybe we started with RNA and
then went to DNA well how did we do that
how did that happen Patrick forterra a
French researcher and Pasteur Institute
argues that actually viruses evolve DNA
first they would infect RNA cells and
the RNA cells would attack them in the
same way that bacteria actually can
attack the viruses that infect them so
there were some viruses that evolved a
double-stranded version of their genes
which protected them and it was a great
way to get into your host and protect
your genes so they wouldn't get cut up
and then eventually the hosts co-opted
the DNA and used it for their own genes
it's a very it's a very obviously a very
speculative hypothesis but it is
something that you can test by looking
at viruses and very exotic microbes and
so it's actually stimulating a lot of
research on the weirder forms of life on
Earth
so that's the past and I just want to
end by talking briefly about the future
I I'm always a little leery of trying to
to look into the future I don't think
anybody does a good job of it and least
of all myself however we're we're here
at the long now and we're thinking about
the future so there are a few informed
guesses that I can make one is to expect
more flu if there's anything I'm sure we
will continue to have the flu the our
children will get the flu our
grandchildren will get it and not only
that but we're going to be fighting the
flu we're not going to eradicate it the
problem is that as I mentioned before
viruses are very sexy they they like to
mix it up and this is a diagram just
showing how two different viruses in one
cell can produce these new kinds of
viruses these are viruses that can
escape our immune systems attack they
can escape our vaccines which is why you
need to take a vaccine every year and
this is a diagram just showing what
happens over the course of a year this
is going to continue to happen we're not
going to be able to stop this process
now every now and then flu viruses take
a shift we we go from different
combinations of the existing flu viruses
to something that's really different
from what we've seen before where do
they come from they come from birds and
birds actually the flu is a gut
infection they get sick in their gut but
it can make us sick in our Airways and
all the human flus all the human flu
strains are just in these three groups
so there's lots more flu viruses lots
more diversity of flu that could make it
into us a lot of these are gonna be dead
end infections but some are going to
make it through
the swine flu the of 2009 was actually a
cocktail of a couple different Pig flus
plus a human flu plus a bird flu it's
just a big old orgy going on that
eventually produced what is now the
dominant seasonal flu strain and you
know I I don't expect us to be getting
rid of these sort of farm factories
anytime soon I expect we're going to
have industrial scale pig farming and
all that means great opportunities to
make more flu now there are probably
going to be other cases where viruses
show up that we didn't even see before
so there's an interesting study that I
have written about for the New York
Times so that came out recently about
hepatitis C infects 200 million people
there are until just a couple weeks ago
there were no reports of any hepatitis C
like viruses out there in animals so
people said well where did it come from
a lot of people thought well maybe it
came from japansese because you can
actually experimentally in fact a
chimpanzee with hepatitis C and there
they were actually being studied in
terms of developing hepatitis hepatitis
C treatments that way well some
scientists actually discovered the the
first close relative of hepatitis C that
thing with the red dot there and all
those yellow guys or hepatitis C strains
they actually discovered in an
unexpected place so you can see it's
called chv what does the C stand for it
stands for canine there were these dogs
that were suffering from respiratory
diseases and kennels and scientists were
trying to figure out what the virus was
it didn't match any virus they had seen
before when they sequenced the genes it
come from a virus that was a lot like
hepatitis C so it's it's likely that at
least
one of the one of these strongest
hypotheses to explain this virus is that
it went from dogs to humans now that
doesn't mean that your dog is gonna give
you a potato see but what it does mean
is that you know viruses are going to
continue to jump into our species
sometimes from unexpected sources now
it's easy when you talk about viruses in
the future to get kind of crazy you know
the many science fiction movies have
been made like this not just rabid but
28 days later an outbreak and you know
there are some pretty insane viruses out
there in the real world Bakula viruses
actually they infect insects and they
grow these incredible numbers they
actually make the caterpillars fat and
then the caterpillars get this urge to
climb up to the top of a tree they get
what's called treetop disease and then
they hang off the trees the virus is
making to do these bizarre things and
and then once they're hanging off the
tree these fad virus loaded caterpillars
literally dissolve the virus releases an
enzyme it dissolves the caterpillar
entirely and the virus is rained down on
the leaves below where they can be eaten
by other caterpillars and if you go out
and you buy a head of lettuce or cabbage
today it's probably covered with
millions of Bakula viruses it's okay
though
you're not a caterpillar okay so you
know when you see that sort of stuff you
say oh my god you know we're gonna get
some incredible viral strain it's gonna
make us all blow up and dissolve and
spray all over other people and I don't
I don't buy that I don't think so I mean
I don't think that the diseases we're
gonna be worrying about it may be things
like Ebola I just don't I think they're
gonna we're gonna be worried about a
replay of 1918 where 50 million people
died billions of people actually got
infected with this this particular
strain of flu quote-unquote only 50
million people died it was able to be so
devastating because it could spread so
easily and part of that meant that it
wasn't totally fatal it wasn't it wasn't
science fiction
he was just horrifying and so that you
ended up with this relatively small
fraction of people who were infected who
died but still because it infected such
a huge part of the planet the death toll
was astonishing
you know another possibility might be an
HIV like thing or a hepatitis C like
thing where maybe there's some new virus
already among us and we don't even know
yet and it's not going to make itself
known for years and by then maybe it's
going to be a global epidemic that's
what happened with hepatitis C and HIV I
don't know I don't want to be too
pessimistic though we have had a few
triumphs so smallpox for example is now
restricted as far as we know only to two
laboratories in the United States and
Russia that's it
rinderpest which is a virus that killed
cows just gone so we have at some
triumphs there you have to be the only
certain kind of viruses can can enjoy
this well can suffer I should say this
kind of fate I think with things like a
HIV we're gonna sort of have a slow
gradual conquest so you can see actually
a Doulton death adult and child deaths
due to AIDS are actually ended on the
decline and there is finally some
research that's suggesting that maybe we
can actually eradicate the virus instead
of controlling of antivirals you know
what I think it's going to be really
interesting in terms of viruses is the
positive side the upside of viruses so I
mentioned you know none of us would be R
without viruses because they help us
stick to the the uterine wall we
actually make some viral proteins in our
brains nobody knows what they're doing
there but they clearly come from from
viruses that became part of us those
baculovirus as I mentioned they're great
for pesticides it's a great way to kill
off pests you don't like and you can
actually genetically engineer the
viruses so that instead of they like to
make these protein balls where the
viruses are embedded kinda like a food
cake you would not want to eat
you can engineer the virus so that the
that it makes instead of the the regular
baculovirus protein it makes any protein
just about that you want and so actually
it's very important biotechnology now we
actually now right now have viruses
building batteries Angela Belcher at MIT
has pioneered using viruses as little
robots as it were to assemble things
just by engineering them so that they
can grab elements and assemble them
together and they do it very quickly and
finally really the the the most
interesting idea the most speculative is
what if we could use viruses to treat
the whole planet you know there's been a
lot of talk about geoengineering our way
out of the trouble we've gotten
ourselves into
viruses are exerting a huge control over
the planets biogeochemical cycles and
probably the climate so if we were to
engineer viruses to to alter bacteria in
the oceans what could we do I don't know
I I don't know too much about the future
I'm pretty sure that humans won't be
around in a couple million years but I
am sure that as long as there's life on
Earth
there will be viruses and that is the
one prediction that I will be I will
make with total confidence so thank you
so much for coming and we're happy to
talk with Stuart
let's go sit that was sensational I
can't think of a speaker who's worked
his subject so far into the long now
thank you for doing that no I enjoyed it
yeah so um one term I came across
recently doing research on mostly
microbes but then seeing how the viruses
are these DNA these gene transporters
there's the term called the pen genome
mm-hmm
what is it and do you think it's a way
to think about stuff so the pen genome
is a term that came up when scientists
started sequencing the genomes of
bacteria so for example they sequenced
the genome of E coli or rather I should
say they sequenced one kind of e coli
that standard laboratory one that
everybody studies called k12 okay we've
got k12 great it's about 3,000 genes now
we know e coli well then they sequenced
another strain of E coli I believe the
the next one they did was one that's
called one57 h7 which is the one that
makes hamburger a little dodgy sometimes
if you don't cook it all the way through
and it was cause the spinach outbreak a
few years back it's not well we'll see
like a couple different you know genes
in it that make it kind of unhealthy as
opposed to harmless ah
and they found I think it was about they
found it like roughly like like a third
of the genes from k12 were missing from
a 1/5 787 and vice versa it was crazy
I mean basically there was sort of a
backbone of kind of e.coli genes but
then there were hundreds of genes that
were not shared by them so you have sort
of a Venn diagram like this and then
they sequenced another a coli genome and
they discovered that it had some genes
in common with one and then the other in
the other so there's and I had three the
Venn diagrams they started to get like
you know twelve circle ven degree
after a while and they said this is
crazy there's no there are very few
genes that all e.coli have they're all
e.coli but you know ecole you know one a
collie might have three thousand genes
the pan genome that is the genes found
in all eco lies I think they're up to 20
or 30,000 genes more genomes and genes
in the human genome so and those genomes
are [ __ ] those genes are being moved
from strangest reigned by viruses and so
it's happening all the time happening in
our bodies it's happening in the
environment so you can't yeah so you
can't just think of there being a genome
for a species things are much more
dynamic and complex than that sound so
you're dealing by the planetary scale
genome oh yeah
yeah absolutely yeah I mean and and
viruses are there are the other things
to do it I mean the the viruses I show
the I showed the picture of the cave of
crystals in Mexico the viruses in there
their closest relatives seem to be on
the other side of the world in the ocean
so the viruses are traveling down
probably through underground connections
across the world viruses travel really
fast you know they showed up West Nile
virus showed up in the United States and
I was believing 99 within a few years
there across the whole continent so they
catch right in airplanes do they also
just you know travel through the air
they'll be more likely to travel in
birds you know if they're if in case of
West Nile virus they'll they'll travel
yeah I mean there are there are plant
viruses that are you know that spread
across countries very quickly and so
they might be riding on pollen and
things like that you know naked viruses
don't do that well in the air
that's why flu virus is particularly bad
in the winter because the droplets hang
mm-hmm so if I sneeze on you it's more
likely that you're gonna get sick if in
the summer I'd sneeze on it yeah right
but in the summer kind of go people
be on the floor out so Kevin Kelley
raises the question with all this
variety
how can you refer to species and he said
there 1500 species of virus on board us
what's the species what's the species I
wrote a whole article about what is the
species and it's it's not even easy to
define species among animals and plants
hmm
when you get to viruses it's it's kind
of a nightmare even with microbes too I
mean basically when I say he's when I
talk about a virus I mean a relatively
distinct lineage that's different than
other kinds of viruses so some of the
microbial guys talk about sort of
functional species like units is that
also apply in viruses or you're just
talking about lineages of genes for them
um I don't think that's thinking about
virus species has gotten that far
actually like a lot of our I'll just say
it just doesn't even matter they're
they're there so you know the idea of
species is something that we really
developed as humans looking around in
the world and figuring out what to eat
and what not to eat and it's it's kind
of a it's a quaint concept that doesn't
really work in the microbial world so a
1500 varieties would you know what
what's that number actually specify if
anything really it's it all comes down
to the tree the the evolutionary trees
so these are 1,500 bigwigs twigs yeah
yeah we're we're you know the the
influenza are you know really close to
each other very very far away from you
know the phages and so on it's it's more
of an evolutionary perspective on it
let the record show he was waving both
his hands very rapidly I'm not the only
one yeah I know we all crisped a lot
glop as a question of phage therapy was
explored in the early 20th century could
it be revived yes it could be so I
didn't have time to talk about this so
thank you
so phages were discovered in World War
one by a Canadian born doctor named
Felix Durrell
he was treating soldiers who were sick
with dysentery in France during the war
I mean dysentery was a horrible killer
at the time no antibiotics to treat them
and he was analyzing them and one of the
things they would do is they would
filter the stool samples and so he would
actually filter and filter and filter
them you know mixed with water and then
he would filter them
finally through porcelain so it's too
small for bacteria to get through and he
had this clear solution and he could
take that solution and then he would we
could put it into a colony of dysentery
bacteria actually a form of e.coli and
it would kill them and he realized that
what he had was viruses that only attack
bacteria very controversial idea at the
time he had Nobel Prize winners saying
you're crazy this is not right but he
turned out to be right and he
immediately said I could use this to
treat my patients and he did and he
would he would go and do one spectacular
case after another of curing people with
phages it was such a sensation that if
you read the book Arrowsmith that's
based on Durrell they made a movie out
of it so you have the movie star now of
this virologist and he actually went
into business the company that became
L'Oreal made these sort of phage pads
that you could use like una' to
disinfect a wound antibiotics totally
knocked this out in the West and so
people all shifted antibiotics
however phage therapy as it's known
survived in the Soviet Union and there
were researchers there who had learned
from Durrell he had visited there and
kept developing the phage therapy Soviet
soldiers in World War one would be
treated with the wounds on the front
should they be treated with phages apply
to the wounds after the fall of the
Soviet Union the idea of phage therapy
started to trickle back into the West
and now that we have this horrible
crisis with antibiotics phage therapy
starting to look kind of attractive
again and not only that lies you to work
around
well antibiotics yes well for starters
you know antibiotics as antibiotics fail
we have very few new ones coming down
the pipeline so we're getting to a
situation where you have certain
resistant strains of bacteria where you
really hope that you know one really
heavy-duty antibiotic works on them
because you've got nothing else
mmm you know we're at that point now we
had this great 50-year run where
antibiotics were the Silver Bullet took
care of everything and we're starting to
come to the end of that where doctors
are dealing with patients they cannot
treat because they don't have the drugs
anymore
so antibiotics were just which are
essentially you know chemicals produced
by microbes it takes a very long time
for them to go through the pipeline and
be developed we've got you know nature
has all these phages just at the ready
that we could just you know and and for
each species of bacteria there are lots
and lots of different species of phages
that could attack them so you have this
ready-made you know pharmacopoeia
waiting and I like that what we can
engineer them now to make them even more
effective so phage therapy might finally
come back this raises a question Ryan
feel and asks with so much death and
destruction why don't we see more
viruses that make us smarter
better-looking or longer lived wouldn't
this work out better for everyone
involved that would be great
well you know me I won't what I Jim be
coming up with viruses pretty soon that
he'll make a smarter and longer-lasting
stuff well certainly viruses are
certainly viruses are an important part
of gene therapy so viruses are being
used as vehicles to deliver genes to so
if you use therapy to cure disease can't
use therapy like that to give you an
expert
or something you you would have to
figure out something that could could
effectively and reliably infect an
embryo or a fertilized egg and always
insert in the right place I mean it's
it's it's a tricky operation so you know
the for the caterpillars it was crap
didn't explode and dissolve but in fact
if you can do stuff like that the
caterpillars it could make them smarter
and more beautiful and longer lift right
I think it's easier to make a
caterpillar explode and dissolve than to
make a caterpillar smarter I'm just a
science writer but that's my guess
back to death and destruction a question
from Barry yeah that's easy
is there any way we would know if irises
have caused pcs extinctions in the past
that's a good question we're in the
future or in the future well it's it's
conceivable certainly the way that there
are some viral outbreaks going on these
days they're they're quite surprising
and how ravaging they are and so for
example I mentioned the endogenous
retroviruses the viruses become one of
us well
koalas right now are actually dealing
with a really nasty retrovirus that is
giving them cancer and but it's also at
the same time inserting itself into
their genome so you have some cause that
have it in all their cells and then
others that don't and in the some are
dying of cancer and it's really one of
these situations where they're they're
just wondering if this could just do
them in I mean it could conceivably wipe
them out unless you know unfortunately
there's there's a few koalas like off on
an island and haven't gotten this virus
but so so yes it's imaginable it is
imaginable conceivable that some species
have gone extinct because of viruses
would we know if that happened I guess
not
well there are some researchers are
testing this by looking at for example
some of the species that died off
species of mammals had died off at the
end of the last ice age and they've
suggested that maybe humans showing up
in North North America brought with them
viruses and just oh then they spread
like crazy through them and so they're
actually trying to look for certain
viruses in the frozen tissues of these
animals so wasn't Spears of his germs we
don't know it could be a combination I
mean certainly when Europeans showed up
in the New World
they brought smallpox that's your you
know that's your tip the scales and no
kidding
question from Chevy our prions
precursors to viruses or perhaps
degeneres or is this a different subject
entirely so prions are misfolded
proteins and they when they come into
contact with other proteins they can
sort of force them as it were to take
their configuration and that's generally
believed to be what's behind mad cow
disease and some other diseases like
kuru I would say that they're probably
the I would just I think that those are
just sort of kind of spun off from
mammals or other you know animals that
are producing proteins and it's just a
weakness of a particular kind of protein
I don't think that it has anything to do
with the origin of viruses but it's a
bring up they're not a parasite they're
poison well they well they they
certainly do raise this interesting
question of what it means to be alive
you know which is a question that people
often ask about viruses and you've moved
to thinking there are organisms
therefore alive yes right so so so
prions have some of the characteristics
we think of as qualifying things as
being alive viruses have more of those
things so I would say they're kind of
alive okay a couple of the scientific
term Kevin Kelly's reaching um so two
questions how much evidence for
extraterrestrial viruses linked to given
the scale of viral natural mutate
do you worry about synthetic viruses
okay
so it's there there's their hat you know
the Levi's fred hoyle championed this
idea that viruses are raining down on us
from space there's no evidence of that
and you know we viruses are very much
part of this biosphere when you look at
their genes they're not aliens you know
but it's certainly interesting to think
about I mean could they can presumably
manage interplanetary travel yes I mean
there's even some bacteria that can do
that so virus is for rockets knocked off
the earth and goes to Mars that can they
have some attacks viruses on board now
or need something for those guys to
infect mm-hmm parasitize in order for
them to prosper right right and as we
saw how difficult it is for a virus to
get from you know a bat a mammal into
humans that's not a done deal because
you know if there is life on Mars it's
probably fairly different than life on
Earth
question from Graham Lynn do virus has
ever hop from humans to other species
yes they do yes unfortunately humans can
sort of bequeath viruses to species
chimpanzees and gorillas are actually
suffering from some of the some viruses
they're picking up from human contact
which is actually start raising some
questions about how much tourism and
even research there should be on great
apes because we can we can bring them
viruses they didn't have before that's
going to put a dent in the eco tourism
business seriously yeah I did read about
this there's some of the mountain
gorillas I guess we're getting what flu
or what from us are we sneezing on the
marrow we're not hugging them very much
we're not we're not but you know we're
grabbing onto plants that they're
grabbing on to and you know I just we're
around we're in the neighborhood qty
bola I know
gorillas are getting hit by
but it's not clear if they're getting it
from us or if it's coming from a
reservoir what's the quantity issue here
I mean you and I are probably swapping
viruses as we speak in each other's
direction only the good ones yeah right
you can feel your IQ Rises yeah well
it's true everybody in the room is
having an effect and I'm just getting
the third diagram whereas the people
watching the video don't get that effect
yeah their loss there's some other
things they don't get though you're cold
but to catch a cold
to get I start to catch a flu it takes
more than one virus it seems like it
takes some kind of threshold quantity of
you know a quantity coming in a certain
level of sensitivity and the receiver
all of that stuff what quantities are we
talking about and if you know if the guy
behind you in the airplane sneezes once
is that different than if he sneezes 20
times uh obviously the more they sneeze
the more likely you will be to get
infected but you know a droplet could do
it I mean there are a lot of viruses in
a droplet so you know yeah it takes more
than one but more than one virus to
ensure that you get sick but you know a
single droplet may hold a whole bunch of
viruses and so it doesn't take much I
would imagine we would be enormous ly
more sicker even than we are if we're
that susceptible to that small quantity
of a bad virus well if if that if those
viruses can get through all your
defenses and they might be enough to
make you sick but it's true well you
know we we are picking up viruses all
the time and we're doing a pretty good
job of knocking them out we're just you
know every day where we're waging war
and sometimes we don't notice it
sometimes you know you may have just
like wake up one day and be like I don't
feel so good and you just take it easy
for the day and the next day you're
you're feeling better that might have
been you know a virus maybe a virus we
haven't yet identified so it's it's
happening all the time so our bodies
maybe do
it's own phage therapy or what well you
there they're doing their own antiviral
therapy there they're attacking okay
what's our antiviral mechanism how do we
usually deal with the viruses we know
it's a standard immune system or
something else yeah well there's there
are lots of different ways you know we
can our bodies can make antibodies to
recognize and attack some viruses we
actually have you know genes that allow
cells that are being invaded to fight
off them we have some very cunning kind
of strategies encoded in our Jone
genomes so for example we have proteins
that interfere with retroviruses so that
they mutate too much they increase the
amount of mutation that happens in in
viruses and basically the may have sort
of a mutational meltdown so that they
become less able to spread so so so so
we are you know our own cells are
tweaking the mutation rate of viruses
which is amazing whoa so I like that a
lot even though not only defeat them by
slowing down their mutation rate they
can defeat them by speeding it up so
they just spin out yeah and actually
there are a bunch of researchers who are
trying to adapt that concept like if you
had hepatitis or HIV you could take a
pill that would ink that would that
would be able to increase the mutation
rate so that the viruses would kind of
go into this mutational overload but
your own cells would be fine and you
know that's actually for HIV that's
actually in clinical trials now keep and
the question of the future you went
through a list of things you expect to
happen you've been tracking the science
and part of your whole point now is that
the science of biology is moving very
rapidly there's a lot of discovery going
on more discovery than there is
understanding some respect what's your
sense of how the science will proceed
over the next couple decades but what
remains to be discovered what's
important what do you think you'll be
reporting for the next while
what kind of scientists are you keeping
an eye on yeah well I you know I'm a
couple things so I'm really fascinated
by the people who are looking for
viruses in extreme environments because
they are really stretching out our
understanding of where viruses live and
what they can tolerate I mean really
viruses are the frontier of biodiversity
because I mean if you took a it's also
the frontier of evolution it's that
they're the big evolutionary apparatus
yeah you describe Darwin is behind the
times well you know I mean Darwin was
fascinated by viruses he just didn't
quite realize that they that you know
what they were capable of but what I
guess what I meant by you know these
people looking for viruses in the
environment is that if you take a
catalogue of all the genes on earth
probably most of them are viral genes if
you look at the diversity like the
differences among genes most of the
diversity of genes is in the world's
viruses so the so if we want to
understand life on Earth and its full
complexity we have to understand viruses
and we've only just started I mean if
you go I mean we have high school kids
doing science experiments where they
scoop up some dirt and they get to name
viruses new you know new species um the
most of the viral genes that you scoop
up in seawater or in soil or what have
you
they don't have any close counterpart in
all the databases of genes in the world
so every so it's not like you're finding
one little sort of minor variation on
unknown virus you keep finding things
that are just out in left field
every single time you
look for new viruses and so so there's
that and then I'm also curious about
looking at what's going on inside of us
you know what are what are these these
viruses doing for us inside of us these
four trillion that are inside of you
right now
what are they doing that's something to
think about
thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]